[Music]
chuck
we're back oh yes we are my friend yeah
so we're gonna i i just thought
at some point i had to lay down some
track here on
the equinox oh i love that gym
[Laughter]
i used to work out there all the time it
was great there's one on the upper west
side
that was 20 pounds ago apparently is
that right
oh you're talking about my corona baby
now the corona baby
coming along oh i i by the way as you
showed your belly i saw your
your your your hoodie you got like
company issue
star talk merch there oh this is so hot
man it's like it's very like design it's
like this
it's like the it's a space shuttle sort
of or some rocket in the middle
blasting off it's an interesting design
it is a great design
i love it it's one of my favorite
hoodies everywhere i wear it
people say yo where can i get one and
i'm like listen
listen to the show and finally
what do i look like i look like your
personal shopper
your personal listen to the show and you
will find out
where you can get one of these because i
don't i don't even have one yet
i guess i'd be wearing nobody send me
one but we got you one
i i guess the boss gets it last i guess
i don't know yeah man it's like going
down with captain's got to go down with
the ship the captain's got to get the
merch last
you got this whole philosophy figured
out hey yeah i just made it up and it
worked so hey
okay so i think i think we're gonna put
a link down uh in the description
yeah i'm gonna check out that and other
merch so let's get right let's get right
to the equinox
the equinox equinox so the equinox
wait say that again i just got to go
there what are the two there's vernal
vernal equinox which is a spring equinox
and the autumnal
which is the autumnal the fall okay the
fall yes
fall and of course they reversed
northern hemisphere southern hemisphere
but they happen
at the same instant all around the world
so the march equinox
that depends on which year and the
cycling of the leap year we are
can happen on march 20th march 21st uh
even march 22nd
and september so it's march equinox in
the september equinox
and i just want to explain what that is
because i don't think everyone fully
grasped it so are you ready for this
okay so
uh equinox is from the latin for equal
night
okay all right so
it means the nighttime hours of night
equals the daytime
hours of daylight okay so so it's a 24
hour day
12 and 12 12 and 12. there you have it
that's a nice day
it's a nice day it's certain it's kind
of a nice day you know what i mean 12
hours it's all
it's broken up perfectly even right
and and there's some history of this
it's faded
i think thankfully in recent years
there's a point where people said oh
if everything is balanced that means i
can balance an
egg on its ends and she had all these
photos the press would go out and they'd
see these
egg balancing demonstrations
all taking place on the equinox and no
one
thought to give egg balancing
demonstrations on every other day of the
year because you could just as easily do
it
uh your ability to bounce like has
nothing to do
with whether there's equal day or equal
night that's pretty one universe
yeah yeah so i think people have there's
been some
improvement in science literacy over the
years so you don't see the press chasing
these things down
uh there are other things to celebrate
about the equinox so here's the point
i'm making
uh that comes about because
every other day of the year day does not
equal night
every other day of the year they're out
of balance so
what's happening at the equinox is
that's the day
where you after which you start getting
more of one
or the other than the other that's right
okay so
for us in the spring we start getting
more daylight than night time whereas
leading up to that day
we had more night time than day right
all right
okay so that's where we're coming out of
winter there
all right and but it's changing it's
changing slowly
this continues until june 21st
and then you have maximum daylight
relative to darkness
and in new york city the last i checked
we get about 16 hours of daylight on
june 21st
and that's the solstice we'll do another
explainer on the solstice
at another time so 16 hours of daylight
eight hours of darkness
we're doing pretty good right there if
you like
you know here comes the sun i was gonna
say if you like sleeping during daylight
okay sorry
all right so here's an interesting fact
well i think it's interesting if you go
to the sunrise and sunset tables
on the equinox and then
do the arithmetic on it
there's more daylight than nighttime
okay well
now we are screwing up our whole
harmonious
uh proposition here that we have
supposedly
equal night okay
all right right so it it turns out
no it's not the case we do not
and the reasons for that equinox you're
such a liar
it's just that you know most things that
we think are simple truths
are you have to arrive at them after a
much more complex understanding of
what's going on
but we like things being simple and that
can be dangerous at times because you
can make decisions that affect your life
or the life of others
without understanding the nuances of
what's happening tell my wife about it
all right so so here's who i got married
so here's the thing it is 12 hours
of day and night if earth had no
atmosphere
and we judged sunrise
at the point of the middle of the sun
coming over the horizon
in the middle of the sun dipping below
the horizon on the other side of the sky
but that's not how we in practice define
sunrise and sunset so here's how it goes
you ready wait wait wait wait wait
wait because i got to get i got to get
this in my head right no no no i'll come
at it another angle don't worry about it
here you go okay
ready you watch the sunrise right okay
and you got the the lion king music
there it is okay
so there it is do you realize at the
instant
you see the sun above the horizon okay
okay it has
it will not rise yet for another five
minutes
so the it is the refraction of earth's
atmosphere
that takes the fully set sun
and brings it up above your horizon
for you to see like a stick bent in the
water
correct or straw does anyone still use
straws bent
in your in your in your glasses in your
soft drink so
so it bends the sunlight up and over the
horizon so when the entire sun is above
the horizon
that's about when the actual sun
is about to come over a horizon if there
was no atmosphere there
so already refraction
threw in an extra five minutes of
sunlight gotcha
already wow that happens so you're
confounding this precise definition
we have of sunrise and sunset
simply because we have this atmosphere
and when the sun is setting
it's set five minutes before you see the
thing set
so there's a whole extra like 10 minutes
it depends on where you are
in the world it could because the time
it takes the sun to cross the horizon is
different
depending on your latitude on earth so
it can vary but around
the latitudes of the united states it's
five minutes there so it's already an
extra 10 minutes
in addition the definition of the spot
that we had localized for the sun's rise
okay so here it is that so the sun is
coming up and just that top edge
so sunset or sunset or to be when that
spot goes below the horizon shouldn't it
right yeah right because you want to be
consistent but that's not how we do it
that spot which is at the top of the sun
goes across the sky now becomes the
bottom of the sun
okay and then we define sunset as when
the other side of the sun
goes below the horizon right
so we're not even defining the placement
of the sun on the horizon
consistently between sunrise and sunset
what this does
is add extra minutes of daylight to
the equinox so if you really wanted to
find the actual day where the actual
minutes of darkness equals minutes of
light
that happens before
the equinox in in march and
after the equinox in the you have to
wait until the
the darkness builds up to compensate for
that
and you got to go back and find that
date so if you're one of these weather
weenies who always sees the sunset
tables and you wondered about this
that's why
wow so now it's you know
next time you're having romantic morning
and you're like
isn't that a beautiful sunrise it will
be in five minutes
yeah just destroy the moon
you don't want to become one of those
well-actually people
what you don't understand is what you
are looking at right now is an optical
illusion
caused by the atmosphere that has
fooled you yeah yeah and then yeah and
yeah look come back come back hey baby
where'd you go
[Laughter]
so anyhow so and and also uh what i
didn't say which was the blunt
obvious thing here you can get on a wiki
page is earth's axis is tilted
and as we go around the sun it keeps
that same
orientation in space so sometimes we
tilt it away from the sun
on the northern hemisphere that's winter
for us and sometimes we're pointed
towards the sun
that would be summer it's the two sides
where we're pointing
horizontal to the sun that's
those instants when that happens those
are the two equinoxes
in the world and on that day everybody
in the world gets the 12 hours a day 12
hours of night
and after that it switches back and
forth so oh by the way that means
everyone on the equator
only ever gets 12 hours a day 12 hours
of night they don't get long
summers long winters nights
because everything is pivot is crossing
through the equator
as one gets longer the other gets
shorter and it's got to go through the
equator to make that happen
so the equator has the least interesting
changes
in the sunrise and sunsets in the world
there you go had to get that out there
chuck well i'm glad you did
i will never look at a sunrise or a
sunset the same way again
okay no matter what day it is
and the equinox it's a fun day and i
usually tweet about it mildly but
you know keeping it going just trying to
make sure
we keep people looking up
see what i did there i see what you do
all right chuck we out
[Music]
okay